wow clear skies out there you wouldn't
even know we had a winter storm
yesterday with the rain and the snow it
is a beautiful shot this morning looking
out to the sun and it is on the rise
just a couple of clouds around this
morning we are looking for a nice sunny
morning but then more residual clouds
this afternoon there's still plenty of
moisture in the air humidity is up near
70 percent dew points in the upper 20s
it's cold I just updated all the valley
numbers got a lot of neighborhoods out
on the west side and the north east side
near freezing still around 40 in Green
Valley 28 at Red Rock teens up at Kyle
Canyon and did I mention snow oh yeah we
had snow up in the spring mountains
yesterday I'm sure you saw it all socked
in up there with the clouds got some
video of the snow up there at Mount
Charleston this looks like it was either
The Visitor Center or the Mount
Charleston resort and you can see all
the low clouds and the snow falling it
was also whipped by the strong Gusty
winds at times too and definitely winter
weather driving conditions so a big
careful might want to give it a day or
so we might even see a little more snow
in the mountains this afternoon as some
of the leftover moisture and from
California moves through teens in
Caliente single digits in Ely this
morning tone upon Reno also have some
teens very cold up there 20s in Indian
Springs and below freezing in Pahrump 34
in Boulder City and 44 in Laughlin this
morning less than a tenth of an inch of
rain that's all we got from that system
we were only a little over two inches
for the year we should be closer to four
inches but we had some nice rain totals
good Springs Southwest of Las Vegas
picked up five about half an inch of
rain over a quarter of an inch out at
Red Rock Lone Mountain in the Northwest
Valley between a 10th and two tenths of
an inch and the M Resort South I-15
south of Las Vegas picked up almost a
tenth of an inch so the rain came in the
snow falling in the mountains between 9
A.M and by 9 pm it was pretty much over
and gone now snow and rain around the
Four Corners today and you see the back
side of this low still has some rain
down around L.A and some snow in the
mountains and I say that has to travel
through today that's my that might bring
us that chance of snow in the early
afternoon in the local mountains
remember what happened last Wednesday
when we had those early afternoon snow
showers and even had a few sprinkles and
light showers over the North End of the
valley all right so 51 for the valley
sunshine to start some residual
afternoon clouds we will struggle to
reach 50 degrees in the afternoons each
day this week mornings near freezing
could even be a little colder this
weekend as we roll into Hanukkah for our
Jewish Community Sunday evening